stimulation, comme nous
l'explique Davide Gentile.
- Est-ce que tout le monde,
vous m'entendez bien?
- C'est jour d'entraînement
à distance pour René, 81 ans.
- Non, je suis bon pour
l'heure et demie au complet.
- 90 minute d'exercice exigeant
avec un groupe d'aînés qui veut
vieillir dans la dignité.
RENÉ DE COTRET OPZOOMER,
retraité
- J'ai gagné plus de "balant"
et ça, ça t'empêche de tomber
et ça t'empêche de te faire mal.
- Mais René et les aînés
de ce programme baptisé WEB-X
font partie d'une minorité.
MYLÈNE AUBERTIN-LEHEUDRE,
créatrice du programme Web-X
- Pour moi, la bombe
à retardement, elle est
maintenant... c'est ceux qui
vont se déconfiner et qui ont
perdu de la condition physique.
- Avant la pandémie,
60 % à 70 % des aînés
étaient considérés inactifs.
Ce qui veut dire
qu'ils bougeaient moins
de 3 heures par semaine
et les confinements
ont aggravé le problème.
- C'est dix minutes
de marche de moins par journée,
ce qui ne parait pas énorme,
mais calculé au bout, ça fait
70 minutes. Et donc,
c'est ça qui a un impact.
- D'abord, la perte de masse
musculaire, beaucoup plus rapide
que chez les plus jeunes.
- De façon générale, ce déclin
est assez important, il l'est
quasiment deux fois à trois fois
plus chez la personne âgée.
- La pandémie frappe la santé
physique et cognitive des aînés.
Dr DAVID LUSSIER,
médecin gériatre
- Moins d'équilibre,
perte de masse musculaire,
perte de mobilité. On voit
beaucoup plus de gens aussi
qui vont à l'urgence avec
des chutes et avec des fractures
parce qu'ils sont
déconditionnés.
- Et pour nos aînés,
les dommages pourraient
être permanents.
- Et même si on les ré-entraîne,
des études ont démontré,
avant pandémie,
qu'ils ne reviennent jamais
au niveau initial. Ils en ont
perdu à cause de ce déclin
et ils ne le récupèreront pas,
alors qu'une personne jeune
qui va avoir décliné va
récupérer son niveau initial.
- Mais le réseau de la santé
ne baisse pas les bras
et attaque le problème de front.
On intègre de plus en plus
l'exercice dans
les établissements.
- 4... et la dernière. Super!
- Gaétane Gauthier Audet
a recommencé à marcher grâce
à l'exercice prescrit
après une chirurgie.
- La marchette,
puis ensuite la canne, puis
je vais marcher toute seule.
- Elle a gardé sa joie de vivre
et veut retourner à son chalet
dans Charlevoix.
Mais la pandémie a pourtant
touché la santé mentale
de bien des aînés.
- Il y a plusieurs personnes
plus âgées qui ont un genre
d'apathie qui est apparue parce
que moins ils ont été actifs,
moins ils sont capables
d'en faire et moins
ils ont le goût d'en faire.
Ça, c'est ce qui est le plus
inquiétant parce que s'ils ne
se remettent pas êtres actifs
très rapidement, ils ne
le retrouveront jamais.
- Et 3, 2, 1! Bravo,
tout le monde! Félicitations!
- René encourage les autres
aînés à bouger pour maintenir
la flamme.
- L'âge et même le surpoids
devraient pas t'arrêter,
puis il est jamais trop tard
pour commencer.
- Avec le déconfinement qui
s'amorce, le groupe s'entraînera
à nouveau dans un parc
dès juillet. Comme pour
la relance des chirurgies,
reprendre l'activité physique
chez les personnes âgées
sera un défi majeur au cours
des prochains mois.
- Je vous aime fort puis bonne
continuation, tout le monde!
- Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.